I only sleep five hours without any help
from sleep poison or medication hi my
name is Kyle hi my name is Sarah and I
have trouble sleeping at night
I am [ __ ] at falling asleep I use
melatonin every night typically for me a
pretty good night's sleep of six hours
well I think overall it's an anxiety
like my brain will not be quiet
I've tried meditation apps melatonin
acupressure mats
I've been on the hunt for something good
for a long time this week I'm going to
be trying luscious sleepy body lotion
which is apparently called favorite user
friendly to kind of see how well the
lotion is working we're gonna be
monitoring our sleep with this app
called sleep cycle I'm very excited to
give this a try it's kind of nice cause
like when you say let's do this usually
it's like you're getting up and going to
do something but this is like let's do
this it's oh I just got out of my night
shower and I've got the sleepy lotion
I'm gonna rub it all over my body
and I'm gonna see if it helps me fall
asleep I am going to try the sky for the
first time it smells really good I
thought it was gonna be a stronger
lavender scent there's little like sugar
flakes on top I think that adds this
like sweet like cotton candy esque smell
to the lavender lotion like candace
marvel at the spark leanness thanks lush
home sleep now I'm gonna go to bed
tonight I might have some trouble
because I've got I'm dog sitting on top
of having my other dog wish me luck
just woke up very saline it's 11 a.m. I
use the lotion last night and it worked
I had a free
good night's sleep I did get like a
proper 8 hours of sleep last night
somehow I have to consider that that
could have just been a placebo effect
being susceptible to the placebo effect
is like sort of my thing so I don't know
if like that's a huge part of it for me
but I feel like it's working I'm a woman
of science so I'm going to continue
using the lotion for a few more nights I
just learned that you covered your body
in sleep poison lotion it made me sleep
passed my alarm while I was looking at
my phone I fell asleep and dropped my
phone on the floor like it's working
well right now like I definitely want to
keep using it to make sure you know like
it's not just in my head but I had a
pretty good night's sleep again Bed Head
is a proper indicator of how well you
slept
I've got like a nice little insane
situation going on up here so that's a
good time people I just woke up today
was the first morning I was able to you
sleep in LA I think I had a pretty deep
sleep I feel like I actually just slept
okay last night and feel a little bit
exhausted actually this morning I think
I was woken up by the normal things
don't wake me up like my dog getting up
or waking up and being thirsty but I
will say it wasn't anxiety or anything
that was keeping me out this was
interesting to see how some nights it
seemed as if the lush sleepy body lotion
really made a difference and then other
nights like last night not really
all in all I'd say the body lotion
didn't cure like every issue I have
asleep but it definitely calmed me down
and helped soothe my anxieties for I use
lotion I averaged five hours of sleep
and after it's I've been getting more
than six hours so that's pretty
impressive I think give yourself an
environment that's conducive to sleep
looks about as exciting as it is don't
drink too close to bedtime I'm a couple
drinks in vodka sodas and I stuff on
that one a little bit and just allow
yourself to relax and then from there
maybe add in some supplementary things
like lotion and see what happens see if
it helps you if it works for you I will
never forget the experience that this
Leslie bee body lotion had to offer me
and the cool experience of watching
people watching me as I walk around
talking about Leslie devaluation thanks